recently we told you on this program
about the wave of demographic change
that has transformed the city of
Hazleton Pennsylvania in the year 2000
Hazleton was less than 2% Hispanic today
thanks to mass emigration Hazleton is
majority Hispanic more than half of the
residents there speak a language other
than English at home now we got those
numbers for a recent piece in National
Geographic which quoted lifelong
Hazleton residents as saying they no
longer recognized their own hometown
they didn't hate immigrants most
Americans like immigrants but this was
too much change in fewer than 20 years
the culture their parents and
grandparents had built evaporated they
never asked for any of that it was just
imposed on them they were bewildered
understandably but not everyone
understands or even cares this morning
CNN ran a hit piece on that segment
writer Ron Brownstein described it as
quote an extraordinary screed against
diversity whatever that means he
suggested we were bigots for talking
about the subject at all this of course
is how you bully people into being quiet
while you permanently change their
country and usually it works because
nobody wants the headache of that but in
this case it's an important enough topic
that we're gonna go a little deeper on
it what happened in Hazleton is
happening around the country
neighborhoods transformed forever with
no public debate what's interesting is
where this is not happening in the
neighborhoods for the people who make
these decisions live here's some numbers
in Storm Lake Iowa only a tiny
percentage of the population was
foreign-born just 25 years ago now more
than half of all residents of Storm Lake
don't speak English at home Amtrak
Michigan had two Bangladeshi residents
in 1990 today that city is majority
Muslim fewer than 40 percent of the
people who live there speak English at
home in his CNN piece Ron Brownstein
suggests this whole conversation is
about white fear liberals often say that
almost always they say that probably to
hide the truth of it which is that the
starkest effects of mass immigration
don't take place in white neighborhoods
they take place where native-born
African Americans live for example not
so long ago Compton California the
famous Compton was the
or just black community west of the
Mississippi today only a third of
Compton's population is african-american
the rest is Hispanic
that's huge change its massive
dislocation nobody talks about it people
like Ron Brownstein shout them into
silence but it's real and for a lot of
people who used to live there it's
traumatic now let's consider how the
other half lives the people who are
making these decisions about immigration
and demographic change are their
neighborhoods changing like Hazleton and
storm like in Compton come on you know
the answer to that LA County is now
overwhelmingly Hispanic but not
upper-income malibu where the famous
liberals live where everybody supports
these changes Malibu is still 80 percent
white 87 percent white actually New York
City diverse place of course but not in
Michael Bloomberg's neighborhood his zip
code is 82 percent white it's less than
5% Hispanic it's still 1985 where
Michael Bloomberg lives it probably
always will be that's the point
same with Barack Obama's neighborhood
here in Washington that zip code is less
than 8% Hispanic meanwhile just across
the river and the suburbs in Virginia
more spanish-speaking every year Obama
loves that he just doesn't want to live
near it diversity for thee but not for
me you see how it works no matter what
Ron Brownstein tells you Lou Barletta
was the mayor of Hazleton Pennsylvania
he was attacked harshly attacked for
trying to fight changes to his city
today he represents Pennsylvania in
Congress and he joins us tonight Carson
thanks coming up good to be here Tucker
so I just want a restate cuz I don't
think you can say it enough that I think
most people like immigrants cuz most
immigrants are great including the ones
in your hometown it's really a question
of who gets to decide what the changes
are and how big they are and I always
wondered for a town like Hazleton do the
people who live there have any say in it
at all no they didn't have any say in it
Tucker and I was at the forefront of
that issue in Hazleton where we saw a
very sudden migration of newcomers
coming into this city with no real
explanation as to why was happening and
why Hazelton and it is startling for a
community that to see a change like that
and to give you a good example in the
year 2000 English has the second
language in the Hazleton Area School
District the budget it was five hundred
dollars five years later it was 1.5
million dollars so that just gives you a
glimpse of how fast that happened so
we're always told that when you bring in
huge amounts of poor people from the
third world with low levels of education
that you get much richer when you do
that that's the key to prosperity no one
who makes these decisions does it in
their own neighborhoods owners but but
they're always saying it's gonna make
you richer Hazleton become richer no and
quite the opposite it becomes much more
difficult when you're when your income
tax goes down our population grew by 50%
but our tax revenues stayed the same
and that's when we realized we not only
had a we had an illegal immigration
problem on top of it all but know when
people are coming in and are of the
lower income or the lower end of the
economic ladder it's less less tax money
that you're getting and it becomes more
difficult to provide services so why'd
all the experts like Ron Brownstein at
CNN say that you're a bigot if you have
concerns and they I mean they're telling
you that you're richer and happier why
won't you admit it sure I you know I had
this discussion I was on a panel with
Mayor Bloomberg at one time when he said
you know New York City's economy would
crash if it didn't have illegal
immigrants who would wash our dishes who
would bust our tables who would clean
our hotel rooms but in small towns like
Hazleton where it's very transparent
it's it's a entire different story yeah
it is
and I noticed that Michael Bloomberg's
census tract in New York is like five
percent Hispanic so he's a hypocrite
like the rest to him you are not though
congressman thank you for joining us
thank you